foreign
for a married woman yeah it doesn't
really work as well the story be so much
different if she wasn't already married
the fact that she's going home and
sleeping in a bed with another dude yeah
I definitely don't like that emotionally
it hit me up inside it's the reality
the person that you have feelings for
right now woke up in the bed of another
man this morning
[Music]
what in the world is going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney show
so grateful that you've joined us we
have a packed house out there
just kidding there's two there's two
two people got up early to go watch a
show hey and for those of you listening
I'm so grateful that you are are joining
us on the show as you know we talk about
mental health we talk about emotional
help talk about your marriage whatever's
going on your dating life your kids
um kids are going back to school or by
the time you hear this kids will be back
in school whatever you got going on in
your life
um Kelly's raising the roof in there get
my kids out of my house whatever you got
going on your life um my promise is I'll
sit with you and we will work it out and
figure out what's the next what's the
next right step what's the next right
step if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz
1-844-693-3291
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask and
um two two big asks that I've got for
you
um I don't like to ask for a lot but
please go like And subscribe to the show
that that does make a huge difference in
how the show gets kicked up into the
algorithms we had our biggest month all
time ever ever
um we ended up the top five last month
it's amazing um to see the support you
guys are continuing to get to the show
and um continue I'm gonna continue to
just beat this drum my brand new book
building a non-anxious life this is the
actual book I'm excited about it
um it is in pre-sale right now if you go
to John deloney.com you can pre-order it
for 20 bucks and we'll send you all
kinds of stuff you can instantly
download a talk I did for a couple
thousand folks on one of the chapters in
the book and uh you'll get the ebook and
the audiobook some folks have asked like
hey can I just get the audiobook you can
when it comes out but it's gonna be like
12 or 15 bucks or whatever so you can
get a hardback copy here I'm
autographing some of these books
whatever so building a non-interest life
this is it if you're watching on YouTube
check it out um go to John deloney.com
and pick it up for 20 bucks it really
really
um helps the final count of the book and
um I I just can't tell you we've been so
blown away by the numbers on the front
end what's up you should say something
well just wanted to make sure people
know the actual date the book comes out
yes the book will be in your hand
October 3rd right if you pre-order it um
it comes out on October 3rd and it
should be in your mailbox that that
morning that morning that's exactly
right yeah and they're shipping up some
pallets up to the building I'm going to
spend a couple of days
signing books and signing books which is
like it's the funnest thing for me man
so um thank you all so much check that
check that out let's run out to
Cleveland Ohio and talk to the Great and
Powerful Bradley what's up Brad
how's it going Dr John I'm doing great
man how are you
uh living the dream sir anytime somebody
says we're living the dream they're for
sure not living the dream
I mean that's the Midwest way I mean
it's what we do
we lie what's up dude
uh
going through life um better question
about relationships uh
met this new girl that's absolutely
incredible and she is in the process of
uh going through a separation and then a
divorce
and just feeling some feelings of yeah I
don't want to say shame but you know
uncertainty like I want to know how to
best support her me like to talk about
wanting to be together and I know I you
know truly care about her I know she
feels the same and you know just looking
for some guidance on how to move forward
with that
how honest can I be with you
I'm ready
so you're you're you've fallen for a
married woman
uh that's like yeah that's the truth
yeah
um
the best advice I can give you
just guide a guy sitting across the
table is run as fast as you can
and I know you don't want to hear that
because she's incredible and she's had
some moments where you can reach out and
actually help her because she's been
struggling and
for the rest of your time together you
will wonder when this other shoe drops
and you're the other guy
another stuff I crossed my mind I would
tell you right now man she's cheating on
her herself she's cheating on her even
if she's in the middle of a breakup and
by the way that's the number one thing I
hear from folks who are like no no like
we're already breaking up and there's
their husband or wife has no idea that
they're already breaking up
right
um I would tell you to
as hard as this is going to be I would
tell you to run
and maybe and even after like she gets
y'all get divorced or she gets divorced
and there's six months we all our
friends whatever then maybe but I'm
telling you right now dude you're never
gonna be able to sleep
have you already had those feelings
or I I I bet let me ask you this
are you feeling weird that she goes home
to her house with her husband
uh it comes every so often but I mean
generally just can't do my best to you
know not think about that the fact that
she's going home and sleeping in a bed
with another dude
yeah yeah I mean stuff I don't like yeah
she's sleeping with another guy
yeah definitely again no don't like that
um
documents on this Crossing line and I
just again just don't think about it or
do what I do I can't just not think
about it but
I I bet you're being Coy I bet you think
about a lot
depends on the day I mean because
honestly there like some days more on
others other days not
um
yeah I mean I wouldn't say it's on my
mind every waking moment I can't say
with absolute you know honestly that's
never there yeah uh
just I mean again just depends on the
day
how'd this happen man
um
I we uh met through some uh some through
martial arts
um
when I first met her
she uh
there's like instantaneous chemistry and
at no point would I've ever thought she
was married then she didn't have a ring
on like just the way they was looking
like there was nothing that was seemed
you know married woman
um
and at that point I knew like if she if
I met her again it would have been a you
know an issue for me because I felt the
chemistry right away at that point I was
in a relationship so I didn't do
anything you know
ah
and then a couple months later well we
met up again at that point I wasn't and
I was like oh you know it definitely
just kind of spurred from there but
I think I just I think it's just so much
of the compatibility like that
instantaneous chemistry but
it doesn't really work as well you know
the story be so much different if she
wasn't already married
yeah I mean the story would always be
different if dot dot dot fill in the
blank if they were taller faster funnier
made more money no absolutely weren't
married right
um
I mean I can't lie I figured it was the
uh
I figured the um what you said there
about running be this you know I figured
that's what you're gonna say why haven't
you yet no but I wanted to hear I know
why haven't you what because I think
about this you met her she was married
yeah and yeah even your own words like I
wouldn't even have known
which told me she was flirty she was fun
she was hilarious she was a good martial
arts competitor like
a corner not uh the Cornerstone of her
life
yeah
you didn't even know about it um so put
yourself on the other side of that man
what happens when when that happens to
you
no I
you bring up a lot of stuff that I've
thought about and I promise I have and
naively or ignorantly I've push it away
um I have it's a lot easier to say oh
that wouldn't be me
um
I think at this point not not running uh
I've been again so easy to call up in
the feelings and the emotion and
right wronger and different we have been
through nothing romantic but we've been
through different things like there's
she's had various medical stuff that
I've been the only person that's been
there with her because
she didn't trust her husband or her
family to be there
um I'm gonna tell you right hey Brad I'm
gonna tell you right now I'm gonna tell
you I'm gonna tell you right now dude
she's playing you yeah
here's what's happening she found
herself in really really deep water
and you happen to swim by so she clung
to you
and she'll cling to you until the Smoke
Clears on this thing
good old school Toronto bonding man it's
not even trauma bonding dude like
there's not a bond here this is a this
is someone holding on to you for dear
life and you like the warmth of that hug
and I don't blame you I don't blame you
at all
um
but you have to see that what you're
feeling and experiencing is not real
it feels so intense and so good and so
right and there's none of it is real
if you were to call me and say hey six
months uh like I just met this woman
she's amazing she just got uh divorced
six months ago and I'm thinking about
asking her out or whatever I would tell
you to be careful then
right but you don't you don't even feel
comfortable being Brad right now you
don't feel comfortable being
in a relationship with a married woman
right
no I don't so what what is it about this
whole thing that is making you
take what you feel and just throw it
away or just put it in a paper shredder
and just keep plowing forward
again I guess it could just be naivety
it could be ignorance could just be
getting so caught up in the emotion
that's there with it
um genuinely trusting and believing that
you know what she's saying and how she's
acting is that she wants that new
relationship that new life and she wants
it with me but ignoring the potential
downfalls in the you know the whole that
I'm digging with it
I would even go as far to say as I don't
know that she's I wouldn't call her a
liar right out of the gate I don't think
she's lying to you
no I mean I don't think she is I don't
I think she doesn't know either
let me just give you the stats on it
yeah I uh 100 of the time I've never
seen this work
now I'm gonna get all kind of there's
gonna be a bajillion people in the
YouTube comments that are like no oh one
time fine
I don't know those people yeah I don't
know
I I don't know
sometimes people will meet some I do
know of people who are like have full-on
affairs and go on get divorced and be
with the person they're having an affair
with and that goes on fine
um
but I can hear in you you really have
feelings for this person
and you understand that you have
feelings for somebody in a house that's
on fire
no that's that's right
so what's your question like how can I
help you I know I've kind of just taken
all the air out of everything
no I mean
I mean the genuine question was you know
how could I best support her or myself
and you know at that point it was like a
future us but the due to us has been
deflated you know probably rightfully so
I mean you know
a lot easier just blaze the trail ahead
without looking around to see what's
going on
um
if this is going to be a hard thing to
hear but it has not been your job to
take care of her
that's been her husband's job and her
family's job if she's in an abusive
situation she's getting beat up whatever
um
that's a whole other situation and that
doesn't sound like what's going on here
and
that separation is not a lengthy drawn
out process
so I would ask you if if she was so
committed to this why is she still going
back to that same house
I mean for her words it was um
finding housing which she just did
and then um with the medical stuff the
insurance was with him so it's just
holding on to it for that
explanations maybe excuses no but
from a psychological standpoint I it
made sense to me emotionally it's you
know just kind of hit me up inside but
yeah and it's still eating you up inside
nowadays
and if you think about it from her side
she got a free pass she didn't have to
deal with the relationship challenges
that she she may or may not have
um she just got this guy that swooped in
and gave her rise took care of money
took care of meals took care of
emotional needs
um she didn't have to do the hard work
of asking for help dealing with her
marriage From the Inside Out dealing
with her family situation I didn't have
to deal with any of that stuff she just
had this white knight that showed up and
ta-da
and the moment that there's not a say a
need to be saved
there will be a reckoning of some sort
um that is definitely something I've
thought about I mean ah
how old are you briefly 26 okay briefly
what were you gonna say
I said I've definitely something I
thought about you know however briefly I
mean once they just ignored it entirely
but after thinking about it being
beyond that it's just a temporary thing
that is just you know clean to the
person that happens to be there
um you know it's a tough time so of
course she's looking for a life raft and
then after that just can be you know
said and done over with
um it's definitely something I thought
about that and for sure something I've
pushed away even more because I'm like
no I can't get the reality but it's the
reality
the person that you have feelings for
right now woke up in the bed of another
man this morning
that's the reality
that's the reality and
at 26 this was probably the hardest
thing you've ever done Maybe not maybe
you've been through a bunch of crap in
your life and whatever but
um
I think the the right the right call
here is
I'm gonna call her on the phone and say
hey I can't I can't talk to you anymore
When the Smoke Clears from everything
and a divorce is finalized and all that
then possibly
um maybe
but I you can't you Brad let me talk
just to you you cannot enter into a
romantic relationship and just start
pretending reality isn't real facts
aren't actually facts right you can't
just pretend like I'm just not going to
pretend that she goes home to this other
guy every night I'm not going to pretend
that we've been
um having deep conversations we may have
hooked up a few times
but she's been saying it just takes a
while just takes a process it just takes
time I'm slowly working on it I'm gonna
do this and we're gonna be together
forever you you can't enter into a
relationship just shoving all that stuff
down it's real it's real and let's be
super honest brother it's killing you
and it should be killing you
there are people who can just be like I
don't care
that's being her and her husband but we
have is between us
and
knock your lights out and that's not you
ma'am that's not you
but you're gonna probably what would
happen is if you did this that would be
like I thought and you said and so
you're just gonna leave me here to do
all this by myself yep I am
and if she turns the tables on you and
starts accusing you of stuff and starts
but you said that now you really have
all your answers
because I would say somebody who's
dealing with a relationship falling
apart with Integrity would say hey
um I like you I like spending time with
you
it's not fair to you to drag you through
what I'm going through right now and I
love having you around but it's not
smart it's not safe it's not it's not
it's not reality
when I all the Smoke Clears from this
then I'll reach out
but until then man please follow your
gut on this one
and your gut is so true and your gut is
saying run brother run
so I'll just tell you I'll speak up on
behalf of your guts run
walk away
and do it with dignity
um
but you gotta you gotta back out of this
one man
you gotta back out of this one
and man you know that you know
sorry man I wish I could have given you
some some happier news to start this
show but
um
she's cheating on herself she's cheating
on her husband she's cheating on her
family she's cheating on you
and that's not a great way for you
that's not a good
um
ecosystem for you to start some new
relationship right now
sorry my brother we'll be right back
[Music]
hey good folks it's that time again
school is back in session it's time to
get back to the routines we threw out
the window in May gotta get up early
drop your kids off pick your kids up and
no more ice cream for dinner your
schedules are about to go Bonkers with
games concerts helping with homework and
a hundred other things but I've got an
important reminder for you please please
make sure you prioritize your sleep for
your kids for your marriage for your
work for you getting seven to nine hours
of deep rejuvenating sleep is one of the
best things you can do for your physical
mental and emotional health and for me
good sleep starts with a great mattress
and that's why I love dream Cloud
mattresses and right now dream cloud is
making it easy with an incredible deal
just for our listeners 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney today that's
John deloney
all right we're back let's go out to
Phoenix Arizona where it's 1 billion
degrees and talk to Rebecca what's up
Rebecca hi it is not quite a billion
degrees but it definitely feels hot it
feels hot
because it's a billion degrees I heard
the other day there was 25 straight days
of over 110.
uh yeah it was horrible especially we
just moved here from Montana oh so I am
not used to this heat why did you
everyone in the planet is like
eyeball in Montana as the sacred holy
place to escape to and you guys are like
nah we'll move to hell that sounds fun I
know yep that's my husband's doing
I mean you got to reevaluate this
relationship I'm just playing I'm
playing
um golly I'm and again I'm from Texas
I'm a lifelong Texan and even Texans are
like it's real hot but they're looking
over to their left and they're like but
it ain't Phoenix man
our cactuses are falling over
yeah it's it's been a huge adjustment
yeah its heads are falling off all right
all right all right so I'll quit talking
about the the weather what's up
yeah so um I guess I'm just gonna kind
of jump I wrote out my question
yeah that's great because I talk too
much that's perfect yeah all right
so I'm a mother of four young kids five
and under and I feel like my patience is
spread just too thin to cover my whole
family hold on a way to try and be a
patient and as patient and kind with my
kids as possible because I know at the
end of the day they don't mean to
frustrate me as much as they do Rebecca
Rebecca Rebecca Rebecca oh yes sorry you
have four kids under five
yes
you are entitled to all the feelings you
would like to have
all of them
there is there is no feeling you are
experiencing right now that makes you
crazy
oh I don't know about that
Rebecca if you said I think about
murdering three out of the four I would
be like yeah that's fair like they're
like you have four kids under five that
makes your house like a bomb went off
inside of it
yeah most days yes
and you're left changing the diapers of
all the survivors that's chaos okay so
you are frustrated and you feel like
you're snapping at people
basically it's just my husband at the
end of the day I I know it's so bad I
like I I've never had problems with
other people too I I'm kind of a control
freak I've been that way for I think all
of my life I'm sure my mom would attest
to that as I'm dressing up my younger
brother in dresses and carting him
around the house telling him what to do
yes you should
um yeah but but I've never had issues
you know it's not a problem when I was
in school it's never been a problem at
jobs
um and even with my kids you know I I
really do I try my best I understand at
the end of the day that teaching them
how I want them to behave is going to be
a process that takes years
um but my husband it's just I I have no
patience no Grace for him it is zero to
a hundred even if it's just the most
minor thing
I just I snap
because you have four kids under five
is he helping at all
yes oh yeah he's amazing he's a he's a
teacher so he's gone for most of the day
but when he gets back and and I mean he
does everything that I ask him to do
but it's it's got to be specific it's
got to be you know it cannot be hey will
you make up some baby food I have to
tell him exactly what needs to be made
how it needs to be made all that kind of
stuff and even sometimes when I do that
he still will do it different ways and
that's almost where I really lose it is
just that it's not done the way I want
it to be done yeah yeah so what happened
when you were a kid and this can happen
you can have great parents this still
happens but somewhere along the way you
learned that you had to be in control of
every variable what does that stem from
um probably I'm The more I've talked to
my mom the more I think that it comes
from the fact that um I'm the oldest of
three and my sister is born with one of
the rarest conditions of arthritis um
she would know everything about it I
just basically know that basically from
the time she was an infant she suffered
um a lot of pain in her joints and
um and and of course you know as an
infant they didn't know what the problem
was and so my mom just did not have time
for me and my brother and she tells me
now that without me there she doesn't
think she would have been able to do it
because I'm the one who got us up and
ready for school I'm the one who made
breakfast I'm the one who when we when
we got home from school was entertaining
my brother where was that letting my mom
sleep and um my dad's a graveyard
um worker he's a sheriff so you know
he's sleeping during the day and then at
work for 12 hours a night you say he's a
sheriff
yes oh fantastic all right so here's
what you have like and and I want to
give you some peace on this okay
um there are some pretty compelling
anecdotal uh huberman calls it anecdata
um
with cops kids of which I am one
yes it is cool but also comes with a lot
of drama because cops kids
have dads that their entire lives are
lived outside the bell curve meaning
nobody gets murdered in the park
except a hundred percent of your dad's
day is dealing with that one time
someone did
and over time it becomes
you know this could happen Rebecca you
know Rebecca hey Rebecca and you put on
top of being a cops kid who's working
the graveyard shift you've been a mother
since you were four
and if you didn't do everything like
your mom said the house shut down
so the stakes have been so high for so
long that if you get one thing wrong
you're out
right your sister goes on whatever your
brother doesn't have food he doesn't go
to school you've been a parent since you
could you should not have been a parent
when you were a kid you should have been
sitting in a mud puddle playing with
sticks
and then you fast forward in that same
skill set kicks in when you have a
chaotic house and I'm making a joke but
I'm being super serious four kids under
five is a lot for a human nervous system
to handle it's a lot
and so your body has one switch it's got
those neural Maps already mapped out
here's how we handle this and then you
have an amazing loving husband who's
like or I could just put raisins in it
and your brain goes and it's and it it
lights him on fire right
yeah
and so your brain is doing exactly what
it's been trained to do so I want you a
to give yourself some Grace stop going
to war with Rebecca because that's not
going to solve this okay
okay also you're gonna have to keep on a
loop in your mind my husband is not my
dad my husband is not my mom over and
over and over and over again
okay
you had no business running your
household as a little girl and yet you
did
okay and so now what you're gonna have
to practice is
um a couple of things number one you are
going to have to just flat get over
sister the I don't like telling him all
the details
you're gonna just have to help tell him
all the details what I would tell you is
these conversations are way better had
not in the heat of battle
this is like hey we've got four kids
under five our whole life is different
let's go out and you hear me say this
like I just beat this drum over and over
let's go out and talk about
making breakfast let's go out and talk
about how we do laundry let's go and
talk about some of these things give him
a list of three or four things of the
way you like it done
and um so be super super clean because
here's what happens you you you are not
looking for the results which are clean
clothes or mixed baby food your body is
searching for the action am I in control
of everything
see what I'm saying and here's the thing
you are not and your your body knows
that but your brain's like I want to be
in control
and then I'll then it creates a
self-fulfilling prophecy where he didn't
want to touch nothing because he always
does it wrong and he's just going to
work a little bit more and maybe he's
going to stay a little bit later in
grade papers which leaves you on your
own more see how this thing just gets
sideways real fast right yeah and so and
then you get more controlly because you
your husband's going away your kids are
a little bit crazier because they miss
their dad and you you grab control a
little bit tighter and then the whole
thing just breathes right like one of
those cactus in the Arizona desert just
falling over right yeah so here's how I
want you to practice this number one I
want you to take them out and distill it
down to a few things you can't live with
here's what I mean by that
my daughter has a peanut allergy I
didn't believe those things were real
and because I was a loudmouth 18 to 25
year old ah the cosmos gave me a kid
with a peanut allergy
when she was born I would take her
places I would go have fun I was trying
to get out of the house and I love you
know doing things with my one-year-old
two-year-old daughter I would always
forget the little bag with the EpiPen in
it and all that
and one day my wife said hey
if unsuspectingly the wrong thing ends
up in a cookie and you forget and hand
it to her she will die
you cannot forget this bag
and I'll tell you I don't forget that
back
there were some things when it came to
how laundry gets done
that my wife's like hey this is how I
like it done and I would say after being
on the road and working you know 100
hours a week at the University
this is how I can get it done and my
wife said okay that's cool
and so it became I don't want to be in
control I just want clean clothes I'm
going to let these things get done in
this way and then there's a couple of
clothes like hey please don't throw my
nice whatever into the underwear and put
it on hot like because it doesn't work
though you know I mean so there's some
basic things like that so I want you to
be very clear about the few things you
can't live with without
and then here's number two you have to
practice letting the rest go and here's
how you do that I want you to ask
yourself when you start to feel yourself
snapping
ask yourself
what's the worst that can happen here
and if the worst that can happen is not
death or somebody getting hurt you've
got to practice letting it go because
you got a husband that's shown up that
loves you guys and is trying his best
is that fair
yeah that's going to be the hard part
though that is such a hard time with
that it is but I mean just think about
this think about every time when you
were a little girl with the front door
opened someone just hit you in the face
with a cream pie just Splat right as an
adult you would make sure you would
deadbolt that front door because it's
your house now and anytime somebody
started opening it you would just duck
it because you've been in the face with
a pie A Thousand Times Ten Thousand
Times this is the same exact thing
you have to remember what didn't what
what kept me alive then isn't is going
to destroy my marriage now
it's not worth it
and it's not real either by the way and
you know that
yeah
is that fair so like go to the other
side of this do this thought experiment
with me
just imagine how cool it would feel
to not be angry with your husband
a lot less stressful
so can I say something crazy for some
reason you're choosing stress
if you think about it why why would I do
that I don't know I'm asking you
because that's what that's what your
body knows
your body knows when there's a bunch of
kids we're supposed to feel this way and
what you have to teach your body is no
no no that's how it was one time it's
not going to be that way in my house
because I get to decide what my house is
going to feel like and I'm going for
warmth and I'm going to go for Joy I'm
gonna go for more laughter than chaos
there's always gonna be chaos especially
with the way you guys did it which is
like hey let's just throw all the
ingredients in the blender at the same
time that's gonna be fine but the
blender is going to get really messy
that's cool but you get to decide and so
that means
that when your husband's taking the
laundry down and you see him put the
t-shirts in with the with the underwear
you ask yourself real quick what's the
worst that can happen nothing there is
no worst here the clothes are gonna
clean
okay cool yeah
can I ask a question that kind of goes
along with that ask anything yeah
because I I think I I'm I've been kind
of trying to do something like that
where I tell him more specifically
but I
I guess if I ask him to do something
specifically and then I still see later
on that he's not doing it that specific
way do you think it would be better to
still just practice that like okay he
didn't listen this time but nothing bad
is going to happen or yes okay you
should still do that but two things one
you can't
if you've got a baby on in one arm and a
baby on the other and one Raptor on your
leg and he's holding the fourth
and you're saying you gotta do it like
this and if you do you got to make sure
this and that he is in survival mode he
is not in learning and listening mode
yeah okay and you are not in teaching
mode you are in control mode I am
barking orders because this is what my
body knows
oh I like that a lot teaching compared
to control mode I like that so if you
want to teach somebody
you get down like when I want to teach
my daughter something I get down on eye
level with her
because I am humongous compared to her
little body and when I hover over and
say hey her body instantly goes to fight
or flight there is no more learning
happening there
she'll do what I say because I'm
humongous she will not learn why we're
doing what we're doing
so I'll get down and I'll look her in
the eye and say hey
and I'll hold both of her hands if
she'll do that sometimes she will
sometimes she won't and I will say
listen if you put this in that light
socket you will die
don't do that and she'll get real
wide-eyed and I'll say I love you and my
job is to keep you safe right see I'm
teaching her in that moment
okay
so teaching has to be done offline it
cannot be done with kids screaming and
blah blah that's why I love like a
weekly check-in husbands and wives and
by the way it's real real important at
your kids age
my wife and I would I would walk in the
door and it sounds cruel and I'm gonna
get a bunch of mean emails I don't care
I'd walk past my kids
I'd say hi guys hi guys and I'd go
straight to Mom
and Mom got my first hug mom got my
first attention
and then we would always say I would say
hi to the kids and then I would say
we have to have we're having adult time
y'all gotta go
and they had to leave the room
and they have learned that even we say
we're having adult talk they walk
they'll just get up and leave because
it's just so wired into them that they
just know that's a part of our home
that they come second to my marriage
the kids have to come second to your
marriage
in a strange way they they will go in
their rooms and they'll play and they'll
do silly things and yes they'll whine
and complain and he hit me
cool as soon as we're done with with uh
with adult time then we'll we'll come
back but that's the only way you can
hang in there in the chaos you guys have
okay
tell me what you don't like about that
um I mean just the days are hard
obviously sometimes but
um no I I think I like it overall I
think as you're saying it I recognize
that we don't really spend a lot of time
just talking one-on-one and we have
twins that are eight months old so those
those are the ones that really take up
the most time right
um but I'm thinking like even our
quality time that we spent together is
at the end of the day we both feed a
baby together and then once the babies
get in bed he's got to go to bed because
he wakes up early in the mornings to get
ready and he he's such a nice guy he
lets me sleep in a little bit in the
mornings too so he wakes up early with
the babies
um but I mean that's our quality time
and it's not even truly alone we're
feeding babies together and but also can
I say this
you've been pregnant
for six years
and a baby an eight-month-old baby is I
I love this it doesn't make mathematical
sense but it's the fourth trimester
right if you look at evolutionary
psychology we traded humongous brains
for
9 to 12 more months of gestation like of
of a baby having to
be attached to his mom so I want to hear
I want you to hear me say this this does
get better
there is a season and you're in it where
you all ride this one out okay
but when you're feeding a baby sometimes
just watching a show my wife and I
watched bones that show with uh I forget
I don't know we watch that boat we still
laugh about it like man what my poor son
what he just in what he learned by
osmosis because we watched that show but
there was some that was important but
then there was also Seasons when my wife
was feeding my son and the TV was just
off and we just talked to each other
that was and that was all we could do
that was it it's all we could have in
that season
um otherwise it was gonna get chaotic
and so
eight months will snap your fingers turn
into 12 months
and then when you're 12 months you're
gonna have a five-year-old and a
five-year-old can be in the shower by
themselves a four-year-old can't too or
in the bathtub
and a five-year-old they're not gonna
wipe properly but they can go to the
bathroom on their own and it's gonna
they're gonna slowly be a tiny little
pinhole light at the end of this tunnel
um and
the one-year-olds will turn into 18
months old
and then you'll get a little bit of a
gap and the Gap will get a little bit
bigger a little bit bigger so right now
I don't want you to do anything drastic
I want you all to hold on and I want you
all to come up with all right what do we
need to hold on in this season
what do we need to hold on right now we
got twins that are eight months old and
we have a three-year-old and a
four-year-old God help you all that's a
lot of humans
a little dependent humans it may be we
need to get some help and I know he's a
teacher and y'all got a family of six
and so
um there's not a lot of extra income
maybe a friend comes over in the
afternoon my my son did some things when
he was younger when he was about 12 or
11 he would go over and play with little
kids my mom but like a neighbor's mom
did some stuff and it was kind of like a
stay-at-home babysitter-ish kind of
thing my son loved it the kids loved it
and the mom loved loved it and because
he was young she got to pay him a lot
less just a couple of bucks but figure
out ways what do we need here
what do we need what do we need and it's
really hard to do that when you have
babies all attached to you so I would
recommend you guys get away for a half
day if possible that may sound insane
and have somebody come over or two
people come over but y'all plan okay
everything in our life is different we
have to prioritize us first
and we have to get these babies fed
what's that look like for us
what's that look like and you my friend
have to understand there's a light at
the end of this tunnel
and how are we going to continue to
prioritize or prioritize what are the
three or four things I got to be clear
on I'm going to die on this hill and
then yes if you say I need the
laundry done the bed made like this and
your husband does it 85 right let it
ride let it ride ask yourself
what's the worst that could happen here
you guys have got this hang on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life my new book I want you
guys to use this as a road map for your
family and y'all can create a world
inside of this chaotic ecosystem you'll
have how do we create a non-anxious
world how do we create this
we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back hey man
how do you call we
people out here
look at this
number one we got we got people
everywhere
it's good to see you beautiful
another one fantastic are those twins
wow all right let's go out to Kalin in
Columbus Ohio what's up Kalyn
hi how we doing
I'm all right how are you good good good
good good
okay so
um
to give some context here
you called in on another show I was
um on the Ramsey show you called in and
you were talking about boundaries with
your mom is that right
yep okay walk me through the original
call here
okay and then and what I what the advice
I gave because it may have been terrible
advice
no it was good it was good
um
so I called
um essentially since I graduated high
school my mom has been asking me for
money
um
and I'm just feeling kind of over it and
um so
but my mom doesn't have a very good
income she has a very low income so I
can't just not give her anything so your
advice was to
um pay a bill directly to the company
and tell her like I'm taking this over
but I'm not giving you any more money
I'm not giving any money directly to her
okay and I don't know if we talked about
this but why does she choose to make
an income that she can't live on
so she yeah I forgot to recap that part
um she's on disability associ
yeah she has this seizure disorder and
her knees are horrible because my
brother beat her that's right that's
right that's right so there's some
family violence in there and then
um so she's on a fixed income but if I
remember correctly does she spend a lot
he just she doesn't even have that much
money because she spends all of the
money she doesn't have like I'll give
you an example here in a minute when I
tell you my new problems okay okay
foreign
so basically I I told you hey
if it was my mom I'd continue to help
her out but
clearly just handing her cash is not
helping the problem so instead of
handing somebody cash
I will take care of one bill or two
bills or whatever but I'm gonna I'm
gonna pay directly to the company I'm
gonna take this burden off of you
yeah okay and so bring me now we're up
to speed so what's happened since then
down and like sat her down and we went
through her expenses we went through her
income we I downloaded every dollar we
talked about like Mom you have to budget
like look you just don't have enough
money right now because you're spending
here and here and here and
um I told her I would take over some of
the bills and I think the phrase that I
used was
I'm paying this
but that is it I cannot be your
emergency fund anymore
um can I just stop real quick good for
like good for you that's that was a hard
conversation wasn't it
yeah I was so stressed about it I think
I listened to our call on the Ramsay
show like five times right before to
like get all pumped up
yeah you were like Dwight in the Camaro
listening to Motley Crue just like
getting ready good job yes all right
good job okay so you had this call
conversation how did it how did she take
it in person initially
it seems to go well I mean she was
Iris
um
but she seemed receptive
and my sister was there too my sister
lives with her and also just gives her
money all the time and so I talk to my
sister too about like I know you live
together and you don't pay rent but you
need to come up with like a set number
that you're paying her every month not
just like swipe my card when you run out
just not be an ATM machine good for you
gosh good for you okay so
I'm assuming that sounded good in
philosophy in theory but then in reality
has been different
yeah
yeah so we had that conversation seemed
to be good I set up to pay a couple of
her bills
um
and then
literally the next week she is calling
me hey do you want to go to a concert
together I just bought tickets
so that was very frustrating yes so
frustrating so now she's got she's got a
little bit of room to breathe and
she chose to buy concert tickets right
yeah and I don't think they were
insanely expensive but like I know they
were more than the amount that we
budgeted for stuff yeah
um and then last week so before I
emailed you guys
um she called me crying on Thursday
um
and said like
I'm so sorry to ask you this I know you
said you can't give me any more money
but
um the property taxes are due and I am a
failure and I didn't budget for them
I I need a thousand dollars
oh
I like kind of sat in silenced for a
little bit and she said or I mean if you
could at least do 500 that would help
wow
yeah so you asking me what you should do
now
on the um Ramsey another show okay yeah
um
so part of the reason that I'm like kind
of done with giving her all of this
money is because my spouse and I are
like aggressively saving to cash flow
fertility stuff
um because we want to be parents and my
mom knows that we've had this
conversation that we're trying to say
about this money so that we can have a
baby
um because it like won't work for us
naturally and
it feels like when she asks me oh gosh
I'm gonna cry it feels like
um
when she asks keeps asking me for money
knowing what we're trying to do with our
money
it feels like she's saying my
desire to not budget is more important
than
you guys being parents
and that's making me feel really
resentful and like I know you always say
cheese guilt over resembles but I'm
feeling both yeah well and let me let me
reframe that a little bit okay
um do you have kids yet
no okay okay yeah that's that's what
you're all working on Okay so
I've got two little ones I've got a 13
year old and a seven-year-old okay
I'm trying to imagine what would happen
if on the way home today
I got in a car wreck
and I hit my head just enough that I
couldn't I couldn't talk as quickly as I
can on this show
and ultimately me and my boss me and
Dave had to sit down and say hey
um
uh we can't I mean we can't have you on
the radio show anymore
they had to go on disability
and then when I was on disability my 13
year old which is just this is funny
because he's the kindest guy in the
world but he got mad at me with a
baseball bat and broke both of my knees
and I went through rehab again and had
to get on government assistance and I
was on disability and I'm never gonna be
what I was and I'm pretty active I'm out
all the time
and so I wanna
I do get the feeling that you have your
feelings are very very real
but just for context I'm gonna imagine
your mom as somebody who's gone through
severe trauma
in her life as she had mapped it out is
nowhere
close to what she thought it was going
to look like
and her body has over time
focused everything on her own belly
button
right
and so yeah I don't think she and this
this may even hurt worse I don't think
she even thinks of you guys
I don't think it even enters her mind
because everything is about the next
second in her life
and because she has
um lost the inability over time to look
up and see out ahead of her and see
other people and experience the people's
lives she just staring at her belly
button belly button belly button it's
all about right now I want to buy these
tickets right now I need a thousand
dollars right now and I just expect the
world to give it to me
because and in many ways she's given up
on herself
and I'm gonna even say for some of that
fair enough
but eventually
people who give up on themselves do one
of two things either they run out of
options and they decide today's the day
like sick and tired of being sick and
tired right you've heard that
um yeah I'm gonna figure this out or
they spiral out
and so my guess is for the first time
you're putting up some pretty
significant boundaries and you're
choosing your your family
your husband and you're in the family
that will be to come
over just being an endless ATM machine
and the way you've done it which is not
just cutting her off and not just saying
forget you you're no we're still going
to honor you you're I'm still gonna
honor my mother and father honoring
doesn't mean I have to do whatever you
say whenever you ask that means I'm
gonna love you the best we can right now
and so I'm gonna pick up one or two
bills
I think that's pretty noble
but I would get
um I would tell you I would get out of
her head as to why she's calling
um what she's not thinking about what
she's trying to do to you and your
husband I would get out of her head
because all that does is weigh you down
yeah it's an exhausting thing to try to
figure out what your mom is thinking
right
yeah and so I would just quit trying to
figure that out and I would stick by our
boundaries and if you and your husband
want to say okay you send us your bill
and I'll tell you this um when people
start budgeting it usually takes about
90 days about three budget Cycles to get
it all ironed out because crap like this
happens like oh I forgot about life
insurance that bill just showed up or I
forget that you know we oil changes have
forgot that
um and so these things just pop up
and so it usually takes about 90 days
three months to get to get to a solid
budget and so it may be that you you sit
down with your husband and say hey we're
on a we were we cut off we cut mom off
but there's going to be an exit ramp
here it's going to be a little bit
longer than we hoped so Mom you send me
your tax bill and me and my husband will
decide
because that tax bill may not even be
real right
yeah I don't know yeah exactly
so you assuming the bill I'll consider
it or you say Mom we're just not going
to do any more money right now
yeah
and um I'll tell you this here's
probably what's gonna happen there's
gonna be tears and she sounds like she's
already tried that calling you I'm such
a loser I'm the worst
we help your poor mom
you said no
good for you for holding boundaries and
then it's going to turn to anger how
dare you
who do you think you are who do you
think you are right yeah
I just don't know like
like I saw her yesterday
um
and like I was just like my whole body
was just like tense the whole time and I
don't know if that's because you always
say to like lead with this my Asus score
is like a nine so I don't know
um if that's why or like but like I feel
like I get worked up easily but
hold on your body's been trying to
protect you for so long Caitlyn I know
and your mom has never been a place
that's safe
and I want to tell you this she should
have been
I'm not blaming her because it sounds
like the whole world caved in honor too
yeah but your mom's not safe
and so constantly putting your finger
back in the light socket and getting
frustrated you keep getting electrocuted
at some point that's on you
and that means you have to deal with you
have to grieve the picture that I'm
gonna have this new husband who's
amazing we're gonna have a couple of
kids it's gonna be amazing and we're
gonna have Grandma time you may not have
Grandma time
or it may be very limited and very
different than how you had hoped it
would be
and you have to also grieve the fact
that we're just gonna start having
babies and that's been a challenge right
yeah and the one person you should be
able to call is your mom and you can't
call Mom
and so that means not that you do
without calling people but now your new
mission is to find a woman who's got
some experience down the road from you
that you can trust that you could reach
out to do you have that
um Maybe
everything in your body will say don't
take a risk with a maternal figure and
I'm going to tell you you've got to you
need that you're worth that
you see how much how much bigger this
picture gets for you
have you been to counseling yet
yeah
um
I've spent in and out of counseling
started going again a couple months ago
how's that working
um
it's good
um I just I haven't been able to see my
person for a couple weeks because she's
been on vacation okay
I want you to get back in as soon as
possible and here's what I want you to
ask in a direct way
I need to work on a boundaries with Mom
and B I need to work on some skills that
when I'm with Mom I stop Outsourcing the
way my body feels
to her energy
that's what healing actually is
when you can be around somebody who's
not okay and you remain okay
you can remember those things that
happen to you an Aces score of nine
means you grew up in hell right
yeah
yeah that you can think back to some of
those things and your body doesn't take
off on you
I'm gonna tell you being on the other
side of it it's amazing
do you trust me that that healing is
real
yeah a promise a promise what you've
done with the skill set you've got is
nothing short of Staggering
it's amazing and you don't see it
because you're in the middle of it and
you just feel every time Mom calls or
every time she's around your heart
starts beating really fast
remember this line she does not get a
vote
do you have any close close friends
beside your husband
um
I have a couple okay I want you to call
them
and I want you to um if you can invite
him out for coffee great
if not cool talk to him on the phone
and just say
I'm going through a new season of
healing especially as I enter into IVF
and all that stuff which is just an up
and down roller coaster it's brutal
um
and I'm gonna need somebody to reach out
to just to say I'm not okay today
and I'm choosing you and I'll hope that
you'll accept that role like like 007.
this I hope you'll accept the mission
and I might text you at midnight I might
text you at 10 A.M
and here's our secret code if I need you
to call me right away
but can I count on you in that way and
they may say no they may say no but I
bet they won't
I bet they'll say absolutely
because you're doing the right things
the hard right things I'm proud of you
but now we're going to move into step
two which is okay we're putting up
boundaries which are great now that
we've got these boundaries up we gotta
get take care of the heartbeat inside
these walls inside these boundaries and
that's you
it's gonna be some intentional
connection with husband that's going to
be some intentional connection with some
friends that's going to be some
intentional disconnection from Mom and
by the way the when the money gets cut
off she'll probably pull away and you're
gonna feel a tension that you got to go
find her you don't not in this season
not why you're getting well
because mom's still not safe
she's gonna get mad she's gonna get
angry all that
mom's not safe
so I'm gonna hold my ground I'm gonna
hold my boundary I'm gonna rely on my
people who I love
I'm proud of you hang on the line I'm
gonna send you building an on anxious
life too
um that's something you and your husband
can use as a road map inside your home
because you have to build something
you've never seen which is a home full
of laughter and warmth and joy not a
home full of chaos chaos chaos and abuse
you call anytime we'll we'll I'll have
you on the show once a week just have
you call in and check in and see what
the latest thing I can help you with
but I promise you there's healing on the
back into this last thing as I said
earlier be very direct with your
counselor about which one to work on I'm
not just going to go and talk anymore
we're going to get very specific
because I need to learn how to live in
my own skin
and unfortunately I gotta learn and live
in my own skin separate from Mom
I promise you can do it I promise we'll
be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings in
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show
um this is Kelly's latest tattoo I
didn't strike her as an emo gal but I
did catch her the other day with her
fingernails were all painted black and
she had like the swoop haircut and I
walked by and she was like it's time to
go right now and then she was writing
poetry about her dad it was the whole
thing but
um she got this one tattooed on the back
of her neck right above her uh her
barcode symbol and it just says My
Chemical Romance real small which is
kind of cool so I was called I don't
love you
and it goes like this
well when you go don't ever think I'll
make you try to stay and maybe when you
get back I'll be off to find another way
and after all this time that you still
owe you're still a good for nothing I
don't know so take your gloves and get
out take your gloves and get out I've
never heard that I've heard take your
jacket take your coat but
take your gloves and get out
better get out while you can when you go
and would you ever turn to say I don't
love you like I did yesterday
dark poetry
My Chemical Romance Kelly's fave I love
you guys bye
[Music]